اذا كانت توثيق بالنسبه لي مفيد يعني
بيعطيني ميزات بيعطيني خيارات افضل من
ناحيه
المقاطع الدعم الفني
على حسابي اكثر تفاعل اكثر تاثير ممكن لا
طبعا
توثيق يكون بمبالغ لانه الشخصيه كمان ممكن
حسابات العامه ممكن لانه
المعرض للانتهاك لا حسابه فلوس
والله ما يحتاج انه يشغل الحساب حقي وما
يحتاج انه اثق بفلوس الان
[موسيقى]
ما يفرقي لانه مردود مالي ما عندي انا لو
في عايد مالتي ما في مشكله لا تقول انا ما
احتاج لتوثيق
ما احتاج يعني ما عندي الشهره او متابعين
اللي استفيد منه في اعلانات او حاجه زي
كذا الفكره اننا يعني ما اعتقدش ان انا
هعمل الموضوع ده لسبب لان يعني اللي بيوثق
او يعمل حاجه زي كده بيبقى مهتم اكتر
بالسوشيال ميديا او كده وانا حاليا الفتره
دي مش مركز خالص السوشيال ميديا يعني يعني
مش مش لازم اعمله يعني الفتره دي لا طبعا
لانه حقيقه انا اشوف المعدن والجوهر في
المعنى اللي انت تقدمه مو في التوثيق
[موسيقى]